the Tia gotten a huge Park in the heart
of Berlin draws tourists and locals
alike the victory column can be seen for
miles around castin frigate takes guests
to see these and other attractions on
sightseeing tours in her 1969 Mercedes
convertible best value in Sicily that a
special feature is that you experience
the city in its entirety in an open-top
vehicle you enjoy a panoramic view and
you don't have a roof or pillars
blocking your view you get a completely
different impression of the buildings
and the city is beauty Boyden from the
Fahrenheit after Caston pflueger
Taylor's her tours to meet her guests
wishes and meets them at their desired
location Ellen Bell and Vanna Baumgarten
are waiting at the brandenburg gate the
couple from north rhine-westphalia have
been wanting to visit berlin for a long
time I'm thrilled to be here in such a
nice car and Berlin it doesn't get any
better than this yeah the best I get a
garnish they head off to explore the
nearby government district on route they
pass by the Holocaust Memorial and the
Soviet War Memorial
then the Reich stock comes into view the
German parliament glass dome was
designed by architect Norman Foster I
stuck the seat of the German parliament
was opened in 1905 cazza will hand the
second called it a talking shop as he
didn't think much of parliamentarian ism
or the Democratic developments in
Germany as you can see the building
didn't look that much different before
but it was badly damaged the bad &
Bockius access to it across from the
right start lies the german chancellery
it's one of the world's largest
government headquarters much larger than
the White House their next destination
is museum island in Berlin's historic
center the complex comprised of the
Buddha Museum pergamon the artists and
neues museum and the alternate soon a
gallery is a UNESCO World Heritage Site
afghan song for mama the museum island
is one of the world's largest museum
ensembles the island itself is home to
five museums the bust of Nefertiti and
the pergamon altar behind us there's the
Berlin Cathedral burial place and house
church of the horn salons the lost
garden rounds off the ensemble on the
path I'm living with a blue jean de
mamon boasts of another of Berlin's
impressive architectural ensembles it
features the concert house and the
French and German churches the square is
one of the prettiest in Germany
Destin trigger is next headed for
checkpoint charlie the famous crossing
point in the once divided city some
dramatic escape attempts also took place
here
the bell juanitas it's regrettable that
the city still hasn't revamped this
place they can't agree on what to do
with it as what occurred here happened
at a very sensitive time it was quite
traumatic especially for building
residents available and that's really
all come out as well no visit to the
German capital would be complete without
an original Berlin kurivolt had two
highways credited with inventing this
courage sausage back in nineteen forty
nine the secret is in the ketchup as
depression I got there are different
varieties in the city but this is a good
place to take a break opinions vary as
to where Berlin's best carry vers can be
found around the city but this one's
pretty good I think of that it's not
only about them Schmitz it tastes great
few visible traces remain that showed
Berlin was once a divided city but I
nita Kirchner straße a section of the
berlin wall still stands today at
potsdamer platz Berlin shows off its
modern side with high rises over a
hundred metres tall it's hard to believe
that this was once no man's land where
the berlin wall stood now it's the end
of today's tour I thought it was a
wonderful tour a great day I think we'll
just have to do it again because
Berlin's so big fatma super I loved it
but in such a fabulous City it was
fascinating we'll definitely do it again
beautify we don't win but for now
they're off to enjoy an espresso in one
of the German capitals many cafes